je lis et ono directrice de l' ong
internet sans frontières
bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france c'est donc une
première victoire du genre pour les
consommateurs oui c'est une première
victoire puisque l'entreprise a été puni
sanctionné pour une pratique qu'elle
avait reconnu victoire en demi teinte
même puisque le principe d'hommes sur
les cinq programmées n'a pas été
reconnue donc on ne peut pas en tout cas
pas pour l'instant affirmer et obtenir
des réparation de la part de la firme au
regard de la loi ont connaissance de
cette du manque enfin de commander un
type de pratiques visant à rendre
obsolète très rapidement des appareils
d'électronique tout de même c'est
encourageant parce que à l'époque dans
une époque le monde est préoccupé par
l'empreinte écologique y compris dans
l'industrie d'addictologie qui en en
tant que jamais suffisamment assez est
une des put enfin polluantes
puisque que ce soit de l'activité de
génération de l'information c'est-à-dire
après d'avoir des serveurs qui tournent
à une vitesse incroyable d'avoir des
smartphones qui sont changés tous les
années qui finissent dans des poubelles
à ciel ouvert dans des pays du sud
notamment d'afrique ou d'asie
tout cela ça aide un plan écologique
importante et on n'en parle pas assez
donc le fait pour le régulateur de la
consommation français de passer par le
truchement de la pratique commerciale
progressé de conduire te réveiller un
petit peu apple sur sur cet emprunt
place c'est intéressant c'est
encourageant mais malheureusement c'est
ça représente sur les forums regardez
faut se rappeler de quelle entreprise on
parle on parle de la première
capitalisation boursière des milliards
de dollars donc dans ce cas plus riches
au monde dont 25 millions c est quand
même relativement très peu au regard de
la fortune de cette rente ou presque
néanmoins c'est encourageant et ça ça
permettra peut-être des verbes plus les
consciences en interne dans l'entreprise
sur la question d'empreinte écologique
de cette entreprise dans le monde cette
transaction pénale prive toutefois les
consommateurs d'un procès public sur
cette pratique de l'obsolescence
programmée même si on le rappelle alain
tu as été qualifié comme tel
quinze mille personnes sont concernées
aucune ne sera donc indemnisé à qui va
profiter l'amande
alors c'est une amende donc
lg va aller dans les caisses de l'état
après caisses de l'état certes iront
certainement comment dire il ya des
principes fiscaux qui font qu'on ne sait
pas nécessairement à quel hacker le
temps dira à quel poste dépenses sont
attribués les amendes pour il est
certain que c'est dans l'intérêt du
public ça c'est ça c'est évident mais
plus globalement je pense que ce qui est
dommage c'est que avec un procès public
on aurait peut-être pu pour la première
fois un débat sur wii il ya neuf semble
être dans ce cas il ya le sait les
séances programmées dans ce cas comment
se protéger
comment les entreprises peuvent faire
mieux pour protéger dans seulement
l'environnement mais aussi protéger les
conduire les appareils parce que ces
appareils que nous utilisons utilisent
des batteries au lithium qui selon les
dires l'entreprise serait moins
performante avec le temps en tout cas
serait beaucoup plus gourmande sur avec
le temps l'horloge en termes de
performances donc la question
une des propositions qui est faite par
les associations et par exemple de dark
dark dawn devrait donc cela devient au
lieu de mettre à jour avec les nouvelles
versions puisque c'est de ce problème
mortis à 6 salut c'est ici c'est à dire
qu'en faisant une mise à jour
en fait on ralentit c'est l'appareil qui
était bien trop vieux pour fonctionner
avec la nouvelle mise à jour
donc certaines d'insertion propose de ne
pouvoir ne pas cadrer à jour contrat de
revenir nos versions antérieures mais ça
pose la question de la sécurité
quand on sait que alors matière anticipe
et la sécurité la protection contre les
attaques
beaucoup d'entreprises hypersécurité
conduire urgent les consommateurs urgent
des utilisateurs a plutôt mettre à jour
vers des versions beaucoup plus récentes
qu'ils ont bien plus protectrice dont il
y aurait eu intérêt à avoir eu ce débat
là sur mon tir dans une cour de justice
en tout cas dans un espace public
c'est dommage il y aura certainement
d'autres occasions parce que des
problèmes se poseront très certainement
avec d'autres d'autres versions de cet
appareil de jardy version de puisaye
plus récente des appareils de
l'entreprise apple merci beaucoup pour
votre réaction juillet ono j'appelle que
vous êtes la directrice de l'omg
internet sans frontières